if you think about like when people die
the only thing that's left is like books
like the only thing that has like stayed
for 2,000 5,000 years is like written
word and so I think there's something
magical about that and so you know I
spend a lot of time trying to make it
really really good and I think there's a
big difference between like publishing a
book and Publishing a great book the
value that people will get is so far in
Access of what they pay that they tell
their friends about it if you can
achieve that ratio then the product
takes off it becomes its own marketing
either it's good enough that it will
promote itself right why would I promote
it because if people aren't telling
their friends that it's good then why
would I want anyone else to read it